chauffeur de formation le voilà employés
aux petits travaux de maintenance
je rêvais ya deux semaines ça se passe
très bien on nous explique un peu
comment ça va se passer
le jeune homme qui a choisi de garder
l'anonymat effectué un travail d'intérêt
général dans une association de
médiation animale
plongez avec les animaux et là qu'on
peut pas reprocher de tout et il a été
condamné à quatre mois de prison ferme
pour conduite alcoolisée en récidive
mais sa peine a été transformée en un
moins d'intérêt général la prison pour
moi un an c'était pas possible c'était
la honte et non le fait de transformer
ça en travaille dans une association des
délits gens et même l'association en
elle même je trouve ça beaucoup mais ça
passe comme une punition on préfère être
chez soi dans le canapé ou mais non
après on a envie relations fait notre
thème le tiges travail d'intérêt général
est un travail non rémunéré il se fait
au profit d'un établissement public ou
d'une association à quétigny annie
nomades accueille ces travailleurs une
fille trois ans on les accueille basse
et ponctuellement ou régulièrement ça
n'est pas un petit peu des besoins et
s'il ya des personnes qui répondent aux
demandes et puis aux travaux qu'on à
faire chez nous imaginée dans les années
80 ce dispositif concerne 1200 personnes
chaque année en bourgogne c'est 70% de
de non récidive le tiges 1 parce que les
gens sont accompagnés parce que les gens
se sociabilise parce que en porte un
intérêt à leur accompagnement et ça
c'est le principal
hui a 25 ans et pour avoir roulé avec un
scooter volé il se retrouve à la piscine
de dijon pour un moins d'intérêt général
je vérifie les toilettes je suis vite
adapté
ils m'ont vite mis en confiance quitte à
choisir vaut mieux travailler ici que la
présence ça faisait peur la prison
un petit peu je pense que la présence
est pas la vie de rêve en fait au
premier thé la prison voit ici à la
fontaine-d'ouche on accueille
régulièrement ses employés un peu
particulier et il est rare qu'il y ait
des problèmes
ça se passe toujours bien la plupart du
temps donc on est content de leur
apporter cette solution cette
échappatoire par rapport à la sanction
qui aurait pu être plus grave
donc c'est plutôt donnant-donnant ça se
passe plutôt bien
de 20 à 200 heures de travail selon le
type d'infraction est dans trois cas sur
quatre
ces peines sont effectués avec succès on
remet les compteurs à zéro et on repart
sur de bonnes bases
ça reste une punition mais beaucoup plus
agréable la prison des peines effectué
en moyenne dont les deux mois qui
suivent la condamnation